hi and thanks for joining us today so
today we're gonna talk about ways to use
an NCBI account in a traditional
capacity as a professor or an instructor
in a college at university or even and
as an AP biology teacher my name is
Rhonda Morris sherry Holland Bailey is
here also I've been in the professor
shoe so I have an idea as to what you
guys do sherry is an expert in the NCBI
account system and my NCBI so she'll
have all the good technical information
if you have specific questions so
professors you're busy really busy in
your capacity you have to develop and
teach your courses and labs coordinate
and run your journal clubs and seminars
direct your labs research efforts write
grants and publications counsel and
mentor your students and while doing
this stay current on everything related
to both teaching and research topics
ncbi has information that would help
most of these efforts but there are so
many interesting records and so little
time to organize them for efficient use
sign up for a free NCBI account or if
you already have one we're going to show
you some ideas as to how to organize
your important lists and use them in
what you're already doing this webinar
will show you how to use the NCBI
account and give you such just some
ideas that I thought of you'll see how
to save searches and get automated
updates when new publications or
database records are available maintain
custom collections of important records
for use in coursework and research
projects create lists of publications or
database records to send to your courses
journal clubs and even research teams
and maintain your bibliography create a
URL to share and often you need to post
your listing of publications on your
faculty profile page we'll show you how
to get a URL to put on your faculty
profiler webpage and finally you can
reuse some of this information to very
quickly create a federal government bio
sketch that you can use in your granting
all with a click of a mouse and you can
keep track of everything right on your
my NCBI dashboard so first you need to
sign up for an NCBI
the steps are outlined here and if
there's lots of information again and
the information provided to you as to
how to do this at the header of
virtually all of the ncbi pages is a
link that says sign in to the NCBI if
you click there you'll get to a page
that looks like this that has a way to
sign in either directly to NCBI or using
a Google account at the bottom is a link
to register for an NCBI account so you
can click this button down here to set
up your registration and if you do
you'll actually see a screen that says
success yay you are signed in to verify
your email address to make sure that
this really is you will send you an
email it looks like this and has a link
to validate or activate your NCBI
account and then you log in and see that
your email address has been confirmed
again the registration page is direct
URL which is listed here and we actually
have an NCBI health book that has
step-by-step instructions or if you
already have an NCBI account you can
sign in and you can actually sign in
directly here which I'll show you in a
little bit or you can sign in with your
Google NIH login or a Commons or other
account and again the direct sign-in
link and there is a step-by-step help
book it just in case you need it now
once you're logged in you'll notice
again at the top header of most of the
NCBI pages there are three links here
one of them is your username in my case
on NCBI professor and that will actually
take you over to a page that will allow
you to take a look at your account
settings here you can actually change
your password if you need to you can
change your security question you can
add additional accounts such as er a
Commons in case you're attempting to get
an NIH grant and there are other things
you can do as well based on your account
that's your username if you click on my
NCBI it'll actually take you to a
dashboard view and this is really what
we're going to look at today because
this particular dashboard view is
helpful to keep track of all of your
various lists and collections the nice
thing is that the NCBI account does have
a health book on the
Zvi bookshelf that really has
step-by-step instructions of virtually
everything you think or you didn't even
know you needed to do on the my NCBI
dashboard
you can customize this page you can
actually reorganize or get rid of or or
move these portlets around these widgets
around to something that's helpful for
you there is a video overview that we've
created that will literally step you
through the entire process as to how to
make this page look exactly as you would
like it to look alright so now what can
you do with this as a professor you
probably already searched lots of
databases pubmed you could search gene
you could search med gen even pubchem
often you want to find and collect
materials for teaching you may want to
keep up with your research competitors
and what's going on in your research
field check on your own publications are
they listed in PubMed do you have one in
PMC yet often you might I have often
been told about a relatives diagnosis
and they want me to check out
information because they think I can
find the information for you you can
actually you need to routinely search
various databases and I'm sure if you
could you'd love to be notified when new
records are available you can do this in
the saved searches widget on your my
NCBI dashboard these are two that are
they are currently on the NCBI professor
dashboard and mullerian lactate
dehydrogenase is a research project and
well my father's age-related macular
degeneration file as well often you need
to create collections of materials maybe
you've got printed list of references
sitting on your desk or digital list
saving on your office computer desktop
somewhere or maybe you've got a wall
filled with sticky notes or a drawer
full of bar napkins that's how I used to
collect them it'd be really great to
find a way to organize custom sets of
Records and be able to access them from
anywhere from your office computer on
your phone if you're in a meeting at
home in the middle of the night when
you're actually doing some additional
work you can do all of this by saving
your lists in your collections with
which again is on the dashboard and
these again are some examples of things
that that I've set up as a professor
maybe a Freshman Seminar on malaria and
the international implications an LDH
biochemistry lab folder and even again
mom maybe dad's macular degeneration now
once you have all of these lists and
you've created these collections you
often need to share them with students
colleagues or administrators so a lot of
reasons you might want to share a list
maybe reading a reference lists for
courses or labs or journal clubs or
seminars maybe again you want to have
that link on your faculty profile page
of all your publications
maybe you need to share them with the
administration so they can see your
productivity yeah you can share these
collections too and we'll show you how
so this is just a quick overview and
again I'm not going to go through too
many details because I'm going to show
you in a demonstration in just a little
bit on the live side if it lets me once
you've actually done an interesting
search you can save it underneath the
text box is a create alert button that
will take you to a page that will allow
you to save a search and simultaneously
set up an alert system that will send
you an email when there are new records
and I'll show you how to do that again
there's a great webinar video that'll
actually show you how to do this or
their step-by-step instructions in that
help book you can create collections
online which you can access anywhere as
an example let's say you do a search in
PubMed you find a really great bunch of
records you want to save a create a
brand new collection with that you can
just click the send to link in the upper
linked collections add to collections
and you can either create a new one or
append to an existing collection that
works if you're on the results summary
list it also will work if your happen to
be on a particular record page where you
can send that record either to a new
collection where append to an existing
collection and it's not just pubmed it's
also gene and many of the other
databases as well and again step-by-step
instructions
the NCBI account help book finally for
now we it'd be really really helpful to
make available or share these lists of
references with students colleagues and
administrators you can set up specific
collection folders just to do that once
you've identified a particular
collection such as the LDH lab
collection that you want to share you
need to change the default designation
over here private means you're the only
one who can access it that's the default
if you change that to public it will
actually give you a URL after you save
it that you can post and share with
people and then people will be able to
see the contents of that particular
collection I'm sure this is a bit
complicated but it really isn't too bad
actually let me demo it for you live so
this is what I'm going to do I'm going
to sign in to an NCBI account we're
gonna do a search we're gonna save the
search and create an alert we're gonna
create a collection we're gonna save a
record to that existing collection and
then we're going to make that collection
public and share the URL for this demo
I'm gonna find some references to start
a student off with a senior project
she'll be researching malarial
Diagnostics focusing in on the
Plasmodium falciparum lactate
dehydrogenase enzyme as a target for
detection and eventually drug design so
the first thing I want to do is sign
into the Maya to NCBI so that I can
start a collection that I can share with
her so this is the NCBI home page let me
show you how to sign into NCBI in the
upper right hand corner is that
hyperlink to sign into NCBI and when you
click it it will open up this page now I
already have an NCBI account so I'm just
gonna sign in directly here NCBI profess
soar now let's see if I can remember my
password and it is still spinning in the
upper corner aha I'm logged in and I
know I'm logged in because now in the
upper right hand corner it doesn't say
sign in it says NCBI professor if I
click here it will allow me to go into
the account settings change my password
I need to the myncbi link will allow me
to go to the dashboard and we're gonna
take a look at that dashboard and these
are lots of widgets there are all sorts
of widgets things like save searches
collections my bibliography sciencv
there is even a blast history widget and
you can click and drag and move things
around if you'd like to or even get rid
of them again there's a video overview
that will show you an actual video of
how to do this and there's also the help
link as well which goes directly to that
help book so first I'm going to go back
to the NCBI home page I'm going to click
the double-helix NCBI to do that and I'm
going to start a search in PubMed to
find up a couple of publications I think
I'd like the student to be able to read
so what we're going to do is we're going
to research articles about malaria and
diagnostic I'm gonna go to PubMed and
we're gonna search for malaria and
diagnostic and and the particular enzyme
I want her to concentrate on is lactate
dehydrogenase I'll run the search and
we'll pull up a number of publications
that are related to this now this is a
senior student and so what I want to do
is just give her a few review articles
for her to look at so on the left hand
side of the screen I'm going to click
review and to make it easier for her
also we're gonna go ahead and click
those that are just free full text
because of that we can pull some that
happen to be in the PMC database and you
can see that here under free PMC article
and she can actually access the
full-text article anywhere she is so I'm
gonna pick a few of them that are
interesting one of them is here recent
progress in the development of
diagnostic tests for malaria here's
another good one biomarkers and their
applications for rapid and reliable
detection of malaria and it specifically
talks about lactate dehydrogenase and
the fourth one why not malaria rapid
diagnostic tests and
like settings those are three
particularly good articles and we'll go
ahead and actually save those to a
collection so what we're gonna do is
click send to collections and there are
three items here that I've selected so
I'm going to add two collections now if
I haven't checked any of those boxes it
would have sent everything I know it's
not obvious but that actually works very
very well if you're trying to do a large
set of pendings so we're gonna go ahead
and create a brand new collection for
this this is directly for the student
and we'll call this oh I don't know
malarial Diagnostics and click Save and
this is going to go ahead and create a
new collection for me and in fact it's
going to show it right here so I'm going
to open up the dashboard and a new tab
so you can take a look and make sure
that that collection is actually created
and added on to my dashboard
here's the collections and there it is
right at the bottom malarial Diagnostics
and there are three articles in there
now I'm going to go back real quick to
the original search and remember I said
it would be awfully nice if it would
just let me know this is an interesting
topic to me what would it be great if it
can actually give me an alert and let me
know when there are new articles so I'm
going to go ahead and underneath this
say create alert and this is going to do
two things at once
one of them is it's actually going to
create a saved search for me I can just
rerun the search again if I want but at
the same time since I Creek clicked
create alert I'm gonna go ahead and say
yeah I would like to have email updates
of new search results so yes please
email them to me or I could have them
emailed directly to the student if I
wanted the schedule monthly I could make
it more often than that but for now
we'll just stick with monthly the first
Sunday of the month give me a summary
report format don't show me the all the
abstracts although they're when i'm
interested and send it most five items I
can do more if I want I'm gonna stick
with
and then I'm gonna click this checkbox
and I like to do that send even when
there aren't new results just to make
sure that I know it's actually working
the nice thing is that not only is this
search actually the one that they're
going to redo but it also includes the
filters review and free full text so all
of that is already included for you I'm
gonna click Save and then I'm going to
take a look back at our dashboard again
and I'm gonna reload the dashboard and
we'll take a look and make sure that
that search was actually added to my
dashboard and here it is malaria and
diagnostic and lactate dehydrogenase
when when was the last search today now
as an example the age-related macular
degeneration one that I already had and
it was searched four days ago because
that's when I created it since that
initial search there are 22 new articles
that have come out with that particular
search so I now have an email alert for
when it you know monthly sending to me
about malaria diagnostic and lactate
dehydrogenase I have a really great
collection beginning collection with
three pubmed articles on it but let's
add one more thing to that it doesn't
just have to be literature it can be
something else as well since I'm act
interested in having her actually do
research on the malarial lactate
dehydrogenase enzyme let's go ahead and
add the gene record for the malarial
lactate dehydrogenase enzyme and the
malarial organism is called Plasmodium
falciparum so we're going to look
specifically for a gene record that will
have information about that particular
enzyme our gene database if you're not
familiar with it is a summary site that
has a link to everything we know about
that particular dream lactate
dehydrogenase there are a couple of
enzymes that actually have that activity
the classic one is the one at the top
that's this one here Plasmodium
falciparum al lactate dehydrogenase so
we're going to go ahead and actually add
to the same collection so we're going to
create a mixed collection of those three
publications we just found and we're
also going to add this gene record so
I'm going to go ahead and click the send
to link got a new laptop not quite sure
why it's doing this then I'm going to
head click Add to collections and it's
going to say do you want to start a new
collection or you want it to append it
to an existing collection and I want to
go to an existing collection I want to
go to that malarial Diagnostics
collection I'm going to hit save and
allow it to append that gene record
directly to that existing collection new
items were added to your collection so
I'm going to come back to the NCBI my
NCBI dashboard here's the malarial
Diagnostics that originally had three
I'm just reloading the page and now we
have four now if I want to make sure the
student has access to this particular
collection right now it's private I'm
the only one you can see it if I click
the private link I can actually change
that to public from private to public
and when I do that and save it it will
allow me to have an actual URL that I
can then share with the student and
here's the URL right here so that's the
URL I can say chef share with the
student and this is what the student
will see my NCBI collections and here
are those four records here are the
publication's and here's that gene
record now again there are YouTube
videos and they're also step by step
instructions as to how to do just
exactly what I've shown you how to do so
if you have any questions there are
plenty of ways for you to you know
depending upon whether you like videos
or whether you like step-by-step
instructions another common thing that
you often need to do as a professor is
to maintain a bibliography listing a
publication listing for various purposes
whether it's populating the publication
section of your CV the department or
school admins annual report you have to
file or even just to list your
productivity on your university faculty
your ncbi dashboard has a widget called
my bibliography now my bibliography is
actually just a specialty collection in
fact you can see it listed in the
collections this collection is is for
PubMed records or PMC listed
publications but you can also add non
NCBI records to it such as non PubMed
journals so if you're a chemistry
professor and you have a publication and
a chemistry journal that's not listed in
PubMed you can actually manually type it
in textbook chapters or book chapters
that you've actually written you can
include there as well you can add those
to the my bibliography collection just
as for other collections once you are
happy with it you can make it public and
use the URL produced to share or even
post on your faculty page how do you do
that click manage my bibliography and
you've seen a page that sort of looks
like this before at the top is a link
right here where you can make your
bibliography it's currently private you
can make it public and again use that
URL just like I showed you before and
here is the public listing of your
publications then you can add that
directly to your faculty profile page or
your web page and people will
automatically see the up-to-date list if
you do it this way you only need to
maintain your my bibliography listing
add new publications as they come out
and whoever has this URL link will
always have the up-to-date list without
you having to do any extra work
additionally you can use my bibliography
listing to export the whole list to a
citation manager for adding references
for your next publication and you can
also use this listing to make a
biosketch to add to your federal grant
proposal without having to do too much
extra work a lot of the instructions
about my bibliography are available on a
help book and also the step-by-step
instructions to share your bibliography
now preparing a federal grant proposal
is hard enough often it gets pretty
tedious ncbi has worked as a team with a
number of other organizations and
federal agencies to create a tool to
help you to simplify the biosketch
generation process
the dashboard widget is called sciencv
you can actually see it down here at the
bottom underneath my NCBI it's designed
to repurpose the information that you've
already listed in your my bibliography
along with stored information that you
put into your NCBI account and for NIH
grants your er a Commons account it
takes this information and populates and
automatically formats your NIH or NSF
biosketch so again my bibliography is a
normal collection and sciencv uses that
information you can manage science CD by
creating a new biosketch and you can
select do i want an nih biosketch or an
NSF biosketch and there are other
agencies and organizations that are
coming online in the future you can
choose your data source whether it's an
existing biosketch or some additional
things such as your a commons or even
orc ID and then you can create your
biosketch and you can export it either
as a word doc or as a PDF so here's an
example than NSF biosketch and an nih
biosketch once you do get your NIH grant
congratulations your my bibliography
will help you monitor your compliance
with the required NIH public access
policy and it will also assist you with
the preparation of your annual and final
reports because you have your
publication listing at NCBI we won't get
that into that right now with this
webinar we've produced others that
talked extensively about this and there
are many documents at NIH and NCBI pages
that will help you with this and the
handout that you were given and that
will also be in the blog will also have
links to managing NIH public access
components I want to warn you or perhaps
alert you to a couple of new
developments NCBI has slowly read and
recently been shifting over to a new
design principle user centered design
this means that we'll be updating our
resources and webpages with more modern
and usable layouts based both on what
users need to do and also rounds of
testing with real people even before we
release them this is may impact you in
the near future in two specific ways
coming in the fall of 2008
there will be a new look for the my
bibliography widget this is how it
currently looks and this is and here is
a preliminary design of what it might
look like when it's released this fall
we've done this to fix issues and solve
concerns that many customers have
expressed to us and we've also come up
with a few of our own ideas about how we
could really make things better and
easier to do we're currently in rounds
of testing right now but one thing I
want to make sure you know everything
that you do now will already be included
in the new system and be fully available
in the system so you don't need to wait
until this comes out start getting used
to the system put your information in
and it will automatically be converted
over and we hope the new pages will be a
whole lot even easier to use than they
currently are and as it gets closer to
the release of the new system this fall
we'll do another webinar to show you
exactly what it looks like and then how
it's going to work another announcement
is that coming in spring of 2019 there
will be a new look for PubMed it's been
a while since PubMed has been redesigned
this is what PubMed looks like now as
I'm sure you know in this recent version
as mobile devices have become more
prevalent there's been an attempt to
make a mobile version which works pretty
well but doesn't have all the full
features including a lot of the myncbi
features we'd like to make this user
interface more modern easier to use and
better on all screens regardless of size
for the past several months we've been
running an experiment called PubMed labs
if you take a look at the PubMed labs
you may see what the new version of
PubMed might be like I'll show you that
in a second but please know that we'll
have a lot of announcements and webinars
not only letting you know when this is
going to happen but also showing you how
to use the new pages so to get a clue as
to kind of the direction that we're
going you can try out PubMed labs the
URL for PubMed labs is at the top of the
page this is an online fully functional
sandbox for testing out layouts features
and functions with the full set of
PubMed data you won't actually miss any
of the PubMed data it's all included in
PubMed labs people have expressed to us
already that
seems to be easier to use and easier to
read and we've been able to add new
functionality that many people have been
asking for it's pretty nice for large
screens of computer desktops but it also
seems to work fairly well on mobile
devices as well please keep in mind that
PubMed Labs is not yet fully compatible
with your NCBI account my NCBI dashboard
but before it's actually released as
PubMed and released to the wild it
definitely will include all of the my
NCBI features
I've gone over a lot of stuff and
there's always more things happening at
NCBI if you want to keep up with what's
happening including information about
new developments upcoming webinars when
we put out cool new YouTube tutorials
you can scroll to the bottom of any of
your webpages and click on any of the
social media links or you can watch a
webinar that we did on Keeping Up with
the NCBI that's on YouTube right now
finally if you ever have any questions
or need help with ncbi resources please
don't hesitate to send an e-mail to info
at NCBI NLM de nih.gov and we'll get
right back to you thank you very much
and sherry and I will be very happy to
attempt to answer any questions you
might have
Thanks right now we're a little at time
but uh we'll keep it open and answer
some of these questions
first one I'll answer because I think I
understand the answer to this question
and then I'll have sherry and Rana talk
about some of the other ones one
question was how public is the public
URL that you create for the collection
and the answer is the that URL is
whoever wants to see you is going to
have to have the URL it's not indexed by
searches and so nobody should be able to
find that the second question is one
that we can talk a little bit about the
pros and cons of these two approaches
the question is do you recommend the
saved search feature or collection
feature we're sharing a systematic
review list of resources and I will let
sherry address that one great question
Brian the answer to that question is it
depends on what you want to do for the
save search is going to give you
everything that's indexed based on your
search so that means that something
could have been written for example in
2007 if that is not in your search but
it was indexed recently it's going to
show up in the emailed safe search if
that's all you care about are things
relating to that topic it is perfect for
you for a collection these are things
that you want to save and refer back to
later so honestly the best answer for
this question is you can use them in
tandem with each other you can pull the
use the Save Search feature to pull all
that documentation for you all of those
citations
then the ones that you would that you
want to keep and perhaps even share you
would put into the collection itself
okay thanks sherry and I think sherry
addressed the second part of the
question which was about the search
strategy which would be present in the
email but not in the collection itself
somebody encountered problems somebody
said that if you have a mixed collection
for example with gene results and PubMed
results that a patron would not be able
to open the collection and I don't know
that that's true well let's cherry talk
about that they've been making changes
to how collections work for the
particular example that Ronnie used she
used a gene as well as a PubMed and you
can try this out in your own account as
well and I just tried it out here it
does work it depends on what you're
trying to do with that collection if
you're just going through and sharing
this information that's fine if you're
taking that information and trying to
incorporate it into another collection
that's where you're going to run into a
little bit of a problem but we're
working on that as well okay so those
are the questions that we have so far
and so I'm going to go ahead and ask for
Onate in the webinar and thanks
everybody for coming and we'll talk to
you next time